so this is a woman who was the four
person on the Georgia grand jury uh that
in the case that got thrown away okay
now there's another case coming but this
is about two months ago and tell me if
the four person when you're the four
person on the jury you're kind of in
charge you're like wrangling the cats
and trying to get everybody who to agree
on stuff now they threw the case away
but you tell me does this woman seem
unbiased and sane and the type of person
you wouldn't want in charge of who goes
and doesn't go to jail
I wanted to hear from
us where everybody in and so I thought
it'd be really cool to get 60 seconds
with President Trump of me looking at
him and being like do you solemnly swear
I'm beginning to swear him in I just I
kind of just thought that would be an
awesome moment
what do you want me to do what do you
want to do with these people like if you
grow up like that girl she probably I
don't know what does she looked maybe
and she's in her late 20s something like
that like a generation of people who
talk like this and they just don't
really care about the law but what I
really wanted was to like sit him down
and like be able to say something in
front of him like that's what I want to
do
it's a miracle he didn't get caught hung
up on that one you know I've heard from
a couple people that I trust that the
the Georgia case against Trump which is
a separate thing altogether this this on
upcoming Georgia case is much stronger
than the New York case that's just a
little sidebar but we're getting some
breaking news right now so I'm just
reading this as it's coming in uh it was
just leaked to Yahoo that Donald Trump
is being indicted with 34 case e
felonies for falsification of business
records today but he will not be
handcuffed placed in a jail cell or
subjected to a mug shot per Source from
the DA's office well that's interesting
look I didn't think that they were going
to put him in jail it is interesting
that they are not going to do the mug
shot the mug shot which of course would
have ended up being as iconic uh as the
MLK mug shot so that's probably a wise
move they were about to make him even
bigger than he is at the moment a little
more info on a classy felony leaking a
grand jury disclosure which sounds like
this is what just happened to Yahoo also
how happens to be a Class E felony in
New York punishable by up to a year in
jail so whoever leaked this thing but we
never find out who leaks things when it
helps Democrats right remember the
Supreme Court uh leak Roe v Wade was
going to be flipped we decided not to
find out who did that right when things
work for the Democrats what I always
tell you there's only one type of
privilege in America it's Democrat
privilege
[Music]
foreign